- [Narrator] We finished the last video
with the assassination of Julius Caesar
on the Ides of March, March 15th, 44 BCE.
And you might remember,
it was done by factions
opposed to Julius Caesar
who that one, he had
gotten too much power,
but even more, he was using
that power to, in a lot of ways,
at least from their point of view,
undermine their authority,
that he was a populist,
and as a populist he was undermining
the power of the aristocracy.
And so they get together
and they assassinate him.
Now you can imagine
that all sorts of turmoil
emerges from that.
At the time of the assassination,
Julius Caesar and Mark
Antony are co-consuls.
You might remember Mark Antony
from the previous video,
one of Julius Caesar's generals in Gaul.
He was also put in charge
of the Italian Peninsula
when Julius Caesar went to
go and take on his opponents,
take on Pompey in Greece.
And so Mark Antony is the
remaining consul, and he says,
"Well, what do I do?
"Do I immediately try to
punish these conspirators?"
In particular, you have Brutus,
Brutus and Cassius, who were considered
two of the leaders of the
conspiracy, and he decides
instead of putting the
Senate into further turmoil,
he tries to have a little
bit of a compromise
and doesn't immediately punish them.
And they're able to go from
Rome and then go to the East,
where they are the de facto leaders
of the eastern provinces.
But then in 43 BCE,
things get a little bit more interesting.
Julius Caesar in his will,
he declares that his nephew,
Octavian, or will be
shortly known as Octavian,
who's 18 years old at
the time of the death
on the Ides of March, that he is,
in his will, should be his adopted son,
and so makes him the natural
heir of Julius Caesar.
Now, Antony, who's also
one of Julius Caesar's
right hand men throughout
and is one of his strong
supporters as he came to power,
he also, in a lot of
ways, could've claimed,
"Well, I have some rights here
"to some of the power that
Julius Caesar has gotten,"
and then there was a
third figure, Lepidus,
and this is a picture
of him right over here.
This is actually a picture of the three.
This is Mark Antony, this is
Octavian, and this is Lepidus,
and Lepidus was also a
significant supporter
of Julius Caesar.
So the three of them get together,
and this is Lepidus's
timeline right over here,
each of these timelines show the lifespans
of these characters, so you can see
when they were born and when they died.
You get a sense of their ages
and when they happened to pass away.
And so these three
characters get together,
and they form a triumvirate,
and this triumvirate
is called the Second Triumvirate,
'cause you might've remembered
the First Triumvirate
between Julius Caesar,
Pompey, and Crassus,
and that was an informal agreement.
This one actually gets legal backing,
and not only do they
form this triumvirate,
but they're given
incredibly powerful power
over the Roman Republic.
And they decide to go
after the conspirators.
So in 68, sorry, (laughs)
so in 42, I don't know
what my brain is doing,
in 43, the triumvirate
is formed, and so in 42,
they eventually are able
to meet the conspirators
who killed Julius Caesar,
and they meet them at
the Battle of Philippi,
which is right over, let me do
this in a color you can see,
the Battle of Philippi, where they're able
to defeat the conspirators.
So after the defeat of the conspirators,
they essentially divide the republic,
although it really is an empire,
they divide the republic between them.
Antony, Mark Antony, he becomes the ruler,
the de facto ruler of the East.
Mark Antony becomes the de
facto ruler of the East,
and then he actually is the
nominal ruler over Gaul as well,
but then he put someone
else in charge there.
And as we'll see over
the course of this 17,
this tumultuous 17 year
period, Mark Antony really has
a lot of his control and
influence in the East.
But they've essentially split the empire
between the three of them.
And right at that split,
Octavian doesn't get
so much of the empire,
but we'll see that'll change shortly
where he's able to be in control
of the western half of the empire
in a matter of a few years.
So after that, then in 41,
and this is where Cleopatra
enters into the picture,
and she always makes this
a little bit more colorful,
Mark Antony decides that he
wants to meet with Cleopatra.
So he's now leading the East.
He starts leading it from Athens.
Then he moves where he
governs from to Ephesus,
and he calls Cleopatra,
and he already knows her,
he's met her several times, to
come meet him here in Tarsus.
And here in Tarsus, and then
they go back to Alexandria,
a romance starts between
Mark Antony and Cleopatra,
one of the most famous
romances in all of history.
Remember, this is the same Cleopatra
who had a romance and a child
likely through Julius Caesar.
And Mark Antony and Cleopatra
will actually have
three children together,
and two of which were
conceived in this time period
right over here, this
period around 41 BCE.
So this is where we are on
the timeline right over there.
But then in 40 BCE, the Parthians invade.
And you might remember the Parthians.
This is another very significant,
you really could consider them
a peer empire to the Romans.
On this map, you're only
seeing the very left
or the most westward tip
of the Parthian Empire.
They had control of,
when you remember the Achaemenid Empire,
the Seleucid Empire, of most of Persia.
They are a significant empire
that was really a check on ancient Rome.
And so they decide to invade.
They decide to invade.
And the Romans already have
trouble with the Parthians.
You might remember Crassus,
one of the first three triumvirs,
members of the triumvirate.
He went and, while fighting the Parthians,
that's where he was killed,
and so the Romans had had some
interest in going after them,
and now you have the Parthians
who are taking it to the Romans.
They've taken it on the offense.
So Antony, he goes from,
when he finds out about this,
and he's apparently in charge of the East,
so it's a bit of an embarrassment for him,
he goes to Tyre, which is the remaining
significant holding that the Romans have.
While he's in Tyre, he
finds out that his wife,
he does have a wife, so this thing
that he has with Cleopatra
is really an affair,
his wife is embroiled in
a civil war with Octavian.
And the civil war, and you'll
see there's this general issue
throughout especially the later
stages of the Roman Republic
and even the Roman Empire,
that as Rome expands,
it needs these armies,
and one of the things
that they promise these soldiers are,
"Hey, after you serve,
when you're a veteran,
"we're gonna give you some land
so you can be a nice farmer
"or at least landlord, other
people might do the farming,
"and you can have slaves
and all the rest."
Now, in order to keep doing
that, you keep needing new land.
So Octavian, in order to make
some of these veterans happy,
was giving away land,
some of which was already,
I guess you could say
owned, by existing Romans.
So Mark Antony's wife was
using that really as an excuse
to try to vie for power.
And just to be clear, even
though there was this triumvirate
between Octavian, Antony, and Lepidus,
things were tense from the beginning
between Antony and Octavian.
Both of them, both of them saw themselves
as natural heirs to Julius Caesar.
Antony says, "Hey, this young
little 18 year old upstart,
"what has he done to deserve this empire?
"I've been beside Julius
Caesar the entire time."
Octavian is here saying,
"Hey, I am now officially
"Julius Caesar's adopted son."
He takes on the name Caesar.
"I am the rightful heir
to Julius Caesar's power."
And so sitting here in
Tyre, Antony decides,
"Okay, let me go take on Octavian."
So he decides to go and
lay siege to Brundisium
in order to defend his wife,
even though he obviously didn't care
too much about his wife's honor.
And it's over there, they're
essentially at loggerheads.
He tries to go into the civil war.
His wife, Antony's wife, dies.
Octavian and Antony decide, "Okay, okay.
"Maybe we should not be
fighting each other so much."
And so they decide once
again to be friends,
and then they really at that point
decide to split the empire more formally
between East and West,
where, in the triumvirate,
you have Mark Antony
still getting the East.
You have Octavian being
in control of the West,
including the Italian Peninsula,
and then Lepidus gets Africa.
And you have Lepidus getting
Africa right over here.
So I'll leave you with that.
There's a little moment of,
it looks like a little bit of peace,
between Mark Antony and Octavian.
But as we'll see in the next video,
it's about to get a lot worse.
The big picture from here is that
they were able to take
care of the conspirators,
but now they're starting to squabble.
The triumvirate is starting to squabble,
especially Mark Antony and Octavian.
Lepidus was always kind of the,
I guess you could say,
the third wheel here.
It was always between Antony and Octavian.
Cleopatra has a romantic
relationship with Antony.
She's aligned with Antony.
At the same time, and remember, Cleopatra,
she's considered the richest woman
in the world at this time.
She is the pharaoh of Egypt.
And remember, Egypt, even
though the people were Egyptian,
Cleopatra is part of
the Ptolemaic Dynasty.
She is Greek, but what
makes her interesting
is that she takes on
a lot of the trappings
and she learns to speak Egyptian.
So she's quite popular from, I guess,
relatively speaking terms,
with the Egyptian people.
And the other thing to keep in mind is
we have these Parthians.
These Parthians have
just laid another insult
on the Romans right over
here when they invaded Syria
and are able to take over this territory.
And this is especially
annoying to Mark Antony,
who is supposed to be
in charge of the East.